How to annual colonoscopy. The doctor said my rectal tumor has nearly doubled in size. I have
been following your protocol to the best of my ability. What else would you recommend? Make sure
that you're that you're running the right this rapid as you can. Number one, put the bulb right down
between your legs. Number two, and then for our nutritional protocol, consider doubly the black
sap blood road. Black sap blood road can be really effective for colorectal tumors, and then consider
adding the Dr. Kelly's Dr. William Kelly's protocol for enzymes, which would be the digestime
plus enzyme by U.S. enzyme to 15 or 20 caps on a waking and a 15 or 20 caps before bed. I know
that's a lot, but if you really follow Dr. William Kelly's protocol with the enzymes that he had
available in the 1960s and 70s, you'd be taking 100 caps, 100 capsules in the morning to 100 capsules
at night. That's almost unbelievable. But that's really the Dr. Kelly protocol. Now the enzymes that
digestimes that we have now are fermented type enzymes, much more powerful than Dr. Kelly's
original enzyme protocol, so you could get by with taking less. But you have to keep it about 30
minutes away from food. You want these to get down there and not be absorbed, but to digest that tumor.
So that's the whole idea of Dr. Kelly's protocol as the enzymes are breaking up the tumor.
So Dr. Kelly's protocol can be beneficial for any cancer, but really for liver, for pain
and for cold stomach, colorectal, the intestinal type cancers. That's really where it shines.